[Music]
the monologue I'm going to do a
monologue and usually during the
monologue I like to confess something
true and personal and private about
myself so today's monologue confession
is uh I drink sure yeah we love drinking
people love dating I haven't been
drinking
that would be a different confession if
I was like what is my makeup in the back
pocket just bottle of gin be you look
like the Sun just a horrible horrible
chauffeur oh I'm not there yeah but but
here's the confession part I like to
drink by myself sometimes and right oh
thank you one person yeah probably a
little drunk already
whoa everyone else may be backing away
because people always freak out when I
tell them that sometimes but why I live
alone I can come home and have a
cocktail hanging out with myself and I
love it why are so many people act like
drinking always needs a witness like I'm
having a bush light call the notary
seriously let me get this straight
if a guy is married and he wants to have
some Merlot at the end of a long day
it's okay
as long as his wife is home but if she
steps out to go to the grocery store
he's automatically in the throes of
addiction she gets home like honey thank
god you're back I got a score to settle
with this month April Tiano it's this
simple listen to this this is true
there's a bad way and a good way to
drink alone just like there's a bad way
and a good way to drink in public so can
it can be okay to do both in moderation
alone you can't be like in your kitchen
just like
I'm not endorsing you do that what I am
endorsing is sinking into your huge
comfortable couch with a scotch and a
good book
who gives a why does that have to be bad
I say it's sophisticated you do that you
just turned your living room into your
den whoo you're dead classy now all you
need is one of those corduroys sport
coats with the leather patches on the
elbows turtleneck preferably maroon
added points if you're not pointing the
Scotch out of a bottle but like a square
crystal decanter you know what I mean
discussing legal matters this has been
decanted classy you got one of those
long haired fluffy cats into the mix
suddenly you're kicking like a rich guy
that hunts other humans for sports
that's class act you like once I finish
this you got 15 minutes stringing the
cross oh I know most of the hiding spots
on the island just keep that in mind
take the RIP to far also the booze at my
house I'll tell you something about the
booze at my house it's free free of
charge you lived in a pizzeria would you
go out to get pizza if you lived in the
noodle factory would you send out for
noodles if I make another stupid analogy
will you understand my point
drinking at homes the best here's
another reason I like solitaire imbibe
Minh we definitely made that huh I like
to keep drunk me in isolation why cuz
it's drunk me it's not the best version
of myself in fact quite frankly it's the
absolute worst version of myself not
only am i doing myself a favor right
keeping my tipsiness out of the public
eye I'm doing all of you a favor as well
you think I'm loud now you should see me
after two sips of anything this doesn't
get any quieter just sip sip also I
don't need booze I'm already a
sentimental guy but you don't want to
see me after a Chardonnay my huge mouth
spitting on you as I talk to clothes
trying to physically pick up anyone
under six foot one getting all mushy
Lent you know I love you like you're my
family I'm talking to a cigarette
machine I just plain don't want other
people to see me drunk a bunch of
spectators standing around watching as I
forget basic vocabulary and try to
control my equilibrium just like look
top-heavy almost fell over trying to
pick up that cigarette machine and
earlier I heard him try and say the word
perpetuity but he sounded like a cat
purring
my lawyer said that the papers were true
in purple to my owner hunts people and
being home alone drunk home alone drunk
that's a reboot I'd like to see
everybody forgets Kevin being home alone
drunk just makes my night at home way
better suddenly that Boy Meets World DVD
is hilarious just me a little sip Arai
Topanga
talking back to the TV like I don't care
what anybody says you're the best savage
brother let the world have Fred I'm a
Ben guy all the way crying a little bit
for no reason but here's the best part
of drinking at home all by your lonesome
you don't need to know the bartender you
are the bartender he knows just how you
like it and he gives the best hand job
this one's on me
[Music]